greetings from podcastville
the joint is brought to you by movement
watchers
listen 2021 is gonna be the year of you
doing it on your own all right
like the founders of movement watches
two college dropouts
that took on the watch industry and look
where they are now
they all sell the best watches shades
jewelry at a fair price in 160 countries
around the world they're making us all
look good
let me tell you something look at the
watch they sent me the element
international waters
with a gunmetal gray band this is one
bad [__]
they also sent me a fine pair of shades
dust sunglasses
and black i wear those for the computer
you know what i'm saying
when you're looking at the computer you
want to keep that on your eyes let me
explain them to you about it
mvmt watches better known as movement
watches
they look like they cost a [__]
million dollars
but they cost what they used to spend on
a night out
that's it you get a beautiful watch
shipped to you
right to your door for free now if you
want to elevate
your look this year 2021 with style that
doesn't break the bank
they got watches that'll blow your
[__] mind get 15
off today with free shipping and free
returns by going to mbmt.com
joey again mbmt.com
joey movement watches it's the [__]
way to go
2021 the joint is also brought to you by
cbd lion listen
enough is enough you know what's kept me
[__] walking the last
six months cbd lion
if you can see the chocolate bar is
missing what do you think [__] ate it
i did
the dark chocolate dark chocolate is
good for you and they have a milk
chocolate 300 milligrams cbd bar
they got 500 milligram cbd gummies
strawberries raspberry orange
tropical they got the roller they got
the this is
this is a game changer the kinesiology
tape
this is a game changer i put this on
both knees at night
i [__] watch tv with my wife and the
baby tremendous
bat balls your saw your whole body you
put this in a bathtub
and you're sitting there like a much
large and when you come out of there
you think 15 chinese women rubbed you
down
and you got vapor any way we can get the
cbd into you
cbd lion has an answer go to cbdlion.com
and look at the fun uh the third party
lab results
read up about cbd learn
what's available to you learn to see if
they can
if they can help with your problem
whether it be pain
anxiety insomnia cbd lion has the answer
go to cbd line right now and preston
joey
and get 20 off delivered right to your
house
all right i think it's 20 maybe it's 10
who the [__] knows
it's a whole new year take a chance
columbus did
cbdline.com slash joey or
church and get 10 off delivered right to
your [__] crib who does that for you
that's how we're starting off the year
everybody wants to get healthy
in 2021 this is the way to go
cbd lion i want to thank cbd lion
and i want to thank movement watchers
for sponsoring the show today
candles lit [__] let's get this
party started
welcome to uncle joey's joy
hey happy new year cup suckers
where you been long [__] week but
it's a new year
new options new choices this is it this
is your year everybody's waiting for 20
it's going to be different well i went
outside [__] friday morning and there
were still people wearing a mess
so nothing really changed and i'm saying
but happy 2021 from the bottom of my
[__] heart
god knows what's gonna happen i don't
see no movement though [__] april
here i'm over here in the [__] winter
so
ain't nothing gonna happen for us here
we're in the house thank god she's got
school
and everything all else is working out
i'm sorry about
new year's eve new year's eve was a
[__] up night for a lot of people i
think that
too many people were on [__] zoom you
know
um i got approached by like three
different companies
to do different things on new year's we
were thinking about
first me rich voss and florentine were
thinking about doing a show
25 people in the audience and live
streaming it around the world we thought
about that
and then i was concerned about the
coveted numbers so
we were going to each do a covet test
and have like a wild and out type
podcast
over at rich's house i thought about
that you know i wanted to entertain
people on new year's eve because i know
there was
there was going to be [__] to do i
wanted to get like 20 [__] joints
you know take the edibles i got and
[__] just get
[__] up pass out on new year's along
with you guys
but something wasn't rubbing me the
right way like the company
the deals were great the numbers were
great i was going to keep it down to 10
bucks
i'm not here to rape nobody you know but
something didn't feel right i didn't
want to do the stand-up because
it was going to be international and
obviously i'm [__] rusty
and i didn't want to [__] do the
podcast either because i just felt
i don't know i was like i wonder how
many people
really want to be on a [__] computer
after on a computer all [__] day and
all [__] week
so i was like you know what i'll tell
you what i'll do i'll keep it simple
i'll just do nothing and then i got a
call from
aussie's boneyard and they said do you
mind calling in
for new year's at 11 30 after ozzie and
sharon i go
[__] yeah what are you [__] nuts
that's like the opportunity of a
lifetime that was like that wasn't my
first off between you and i and the
[__] and mike
and the [__] four walls if it wasn't
for houses boneyard i would have been
better 10 o'clock
10 30 just like last year i go to bed
early on new year's eve
i just want to wake up to a new [__]
horizon that's
it i don't want to hear what comes with
the fireworks
mexican shooting guns chinese people
throwing buckets of water i don't want
to [__] deal with this [__] so
i just usually go to bed but once they
said do you want to do the [__] keep
the
[__] yeah and then i figured you know
what i'll do this is my plan guys this
is where my heart is
just so you know i was going to do a a
stream through youtube for my patreon
people
so they could see
my zoom interview with keith throughout
you know like a behind the scenes type
thing just to you know
just to [__] give you something i
knew he is different
instead of me sitting here smoking a
[__] joint talking stupidity
that's something different a little
behind the scenes we were on [__]
zoom
and and then once that ended i would
have smoked the joint with you
and we would have done the countdown and
at 12 o'clock i would have [__]
broken the camera
and everybody goes to sleep that was the
plan
but when i got in everything was already
set up before i left to go to my
friend's house
we set everything up me and my wife
everything was ready to [__] go
when we got back in here the [__]
zoom didn't work the ozzie's boneyard
and and here i'm on zoom i'm
on the zoom and i'm watching mark weiss
i'm seeing the the other singer from
not slaughter some other singer
sebastian bach
i'm watching all these [__] guys on
zoom that they're going to call into
ozzie's boneyard
but we're all talking together but
the host not keith uh his assistant the
guy
he couldn't hear me we're going back and
forth though [__] 11 40 we're going
back and forth
it had to be 11 40 11 38 and finally the
guy hung up a sign and just said call
so that [__] up the whole [__]
zoom thing so now i had a call so i was
gonna
stream through my phone so i had to take
the [__] phone down
and call ozzie bonyard great
great [__] whatever i had a great
time it was an
honor you know i grew up on ozzie love
everything about him
uh had a great time but then we went
over and then i went looking for the
[__] link on youtube to connect with
you guys
and the link was gone
so i go [__] it i must have made i must
have made six links
you i don't know if you've ever youtube
live they always tell you
just when you set the appointment you
gotta take a picture
i took it like sometimes i don't even
know the pictures come my glasses are
sideways whatever
i just pressed the [__] thing and the
picture took
you know any pictures i took six
pictures and the thing wouldn't
let me log on
then i [__] come in just the same way
me and mike
do it i [__] logged in the microphone
the same way i do the morning music
the patreon i logged in the microphone
did the whole [__] thing
had a great time smoked the tremendous
joy us from wikiweed
[__] out of out of la tremendous
w-i-k-i
oh they sent me a [__] bag of it
tremendous i had a [__] uh or my boys
out of urban trees
one of my boys flew back for a couple
days and he dropped off a bag
you understand me so i was about to
smoke 15 joints with you guys
so i did the best i could i did like a
15 minute video breaking down a year the
year in review whatever
i put the video up i'm happy as [__]
i make the tape for the next morning
and next thing you know i wake up the
next day and then like they got no audio
on it
but then i started hearing people having
problems
i know that jessie may peluso was going
to do them with josh wolfe
and that didn't go down josh wolfe
couldn't get his started either
i heard there were problems with burke
prices and tom segura's live stream
so you know what i knew it wasn't just
me
what happened was i guess you
[__] didn't get enough
[__] zoom and you were still zooming
on [__] new year's eve
so you [__] it up for everybody with
your [__] zooms
well you can't pick up the phone like a
normal human being i see that [__]
sometimes like on facebook like
12 idiots like the brady bunch getting
together and talking well
are you [__] [__] i can't i can't
do that i can't keep up with
about three months ago one of my
childhood friends
who i i loved to that he was on the show
stephenville i loved
all my heart he hit me up and he goes
let's do a zoom
with a bunch of us from high school and
i tried
the zoom went down thank god that night
my zoom had gone down this is
i think this is back in l.a i was here
it was here the zoom went down
and i was like kind of happy because
there was too many faces
i couldn't [__] deal with it i just i
i'm just not [__] good at it
but anyway we're here it's 20 21.
something interesting happened to me
last week that uh i feel a lot better
about i listen this has been a long
[__] journey for me unwinding from
this whole
uh experience you know it's been great
we had a great holiday listen man
my my kid's happier than she's ever been
my kid's happier and on top of things
more than she's ever been
if i've ever done anything right this
was it
but at the same time i started getting
doubts
you know i talk to you people all the
time about different things
doubt is one of those things that you
can't ever get
and for years i avoided doubt like a
[__] there's two things i avoid
doubt and thinking too much will [__]
destroy your insides
and if you doubt yourself you're gonna
have it and lately
i've been doing both of them and it's
[__] me up and you could see it you
could hear it in my voice
you could see it on my podcast you can
see me when i'm on stage
i'm excited about this week because i
got vinnie's tuesday and wednesday i got
two sets
back to back i'm excited about this the
first time
i have two sets back to back since last
[__] january
how's that for you back-to-back night so
yeah
it had to be last february how's that
for you
so you know i have the surgery on friday
uh i got doctor's appointments all
[__] weak i'm [__] swamped out the
ass
but
the thing that's been really bothering
me ever since i got off the plane was
what i was gonna do with my life
you know my life has changed completely
you know once i watched
the comedy store documentary
that was the end that was the end for me
like that was like telling me like a
goodbye
on film you know so since i've
watched that i've had my doubts about my
life and stand up i'm gonna be 58
in [__] february i'm not a spring
chicken anymore
you know so i've had my doubts lately i
don't know you know i
spoke to ronald white on the phone a few
times you guys saw him on rogan talking
about him retiring
so i was like maybe you know i don't i
don't know i don't know how much
longer you know i don't like sucking at
something i was really good at at one
time
i don't like it i don't like sucking at
something i was really good at it one
time that was it was like second nature
to me
stand up and now i go up then i'm kind
of clunky and i know that i just need
three weeks of [__] like triple runs
like just getting up there and working
them out and banging them out but
that's not available right now they'll
become available
in april and april once they start
opening up [__] outside
stuff once the vaccine you know i think
that we'll be back indoors
next september i'm hearing that
buildings in new york aren't allowed
you're not allowed to go back till july
i'm talking about stand-up comedy
you know i'm gonna have this surgery on
friday
i'm gonna take like two or three weeks
off just to get
you know my legs squared away and the
first week of february i'm back at uncle
vinnie's in point pleasant
and i'm gonna be straight there every
wednesday on
that's just the way it's gonna be until
this opens back
up and i could do comedy on a [__]
regular basis but
i just recently decided that and what
made me decide as dumb as it seems
what may be decided is sylvester
stallone
the other night i watched the movie
rocky about ball
listen if it wasn't for sylvester
stallone during this pandemic
i think i would have killed myself
between the rambos
and the [__] rockies they've been on
every [__] night
and you know what you just put them on
some nights just to
kill time it's not even like you're
watching them anymore
you know every [__] line of it but i
didn't remember this rocky about ball
one
i don't think i saw it maybe i was on
the road maybe i was too busy with my
life
it's about him being 58 and
they did like a computerized generalized
one of those computer fights
and he actually beats the champion who
was at the time
this big african american guy and uh
it just you know like it made him think
like
what if you know obviously they went to
see him two guys and they gave him a
[__] ear beating
about why he should box again and all
this [__]
and he went in front of the board and
they told him he was too old and
you know i i didn't even watch the rest
of the movie i got caught up
with something it didn't really matter
but
when he went in front of his board
hearing they told him that
they rejected his license because he was
too old and he was
you know that they didn't want to be
responsible for him that they felt like
they would you know
put him out there to be killed and he
was going what does age have to do with
it
what does being 58 want to do with it
you're telling me i can't do what i want
to do at 58
because you're scared for me why would
you be scared for me
let me do what i'm gonna do i'm not
gonna sue anybody his whole rap was that
you're not dead at 58. i'm not dead yet
i'm not dead at 58. it's so weird like
when you're 20 and you think of 30
or 40 or 60 you're like that's [__]
old
guys i don't know if you know this
[__] kids did a show new year's eve
imagine being 70 with heels on
on [__] stage singing detroit rock
city
you know the 70 is like the new 50.
when i was a kid 50 you were [__] old
and 70 you people just blew dust off
here
people just stuck you with darts like
you're dead you're gonna die any [__]
day you're like a boss
now people have [__] lives so i'm
sitting there watching this
and i'm like you know what i'm not dead
yet
i'm not dead yet maybe you know maybe
i'm feeling this way about calmly
because i'm not doing it every night
so i decided to do a bunch of [__]
things differently
that's why i didn't finish the movie i
didn't finish the movie because it
motivated me watching that so much
but i waited till mercy went to bed i
went upstairs i kissed her i
usually put her up there at nine and
then i go in there around 9
30 she's still reading she stays up to
like 10 i don't [__] know
i went in there about 9 30 and gave her
a kiss and i ran down to the office
and i just really really wanted to think
about what i wanted to [__] do
and i got i went back old school you
know me dog i'm an old school
[__]
i go back to what works i made a line
if you want i go get it and show it to
you [__] horrible i made a line
and uh i put my weaknesses and my
strengths
and i was as brutally honest as i could
be because i'm brutally honest with
myself that's one thing about me dog
that a lot of people don't have i'm
brutally honest with myself
i'll tell you when something sucks and
i'll tell you when something's good if
something's good i'll tell you
if i feel good about it i'll [__]
tell you you know i hate my specials i
hate anything i ever did with specials
[__] hari storyteller shows
i love those but my specials [__]
sucked
i did 800 church episodes 400 of them
are [__] spectacular
400 of them suck i've done 26 of these
26 of these suck but you know what
we're still gonna keep pushing because i
know
you got to keep pushing eventually you
got to keep pushing
you know how many [__] sets i did to
get good at doing comedy
a lot a lot four to 500 sets a [__]
year
that's two sets of [__] night you
know that's what you got to do
that's the work effort that needs to get
put in but that's not what i'm we're
talking about
i just made a list of my strengths and
my weaknesses i was as brutally honest
as i could
you know i'm i'm
i'm very uh i'm not a procrastinator
you know i take something i either do it
or i'm not gonna do it i know
i'm either going to do it i'm not going
to do it there's no thinking about it
give me a day or two if i tell you give
me a day or two that means i'm not going
to do it
everybody knows that even mike knows
that if i want to do something i'll do
it you know
and uh
the weaknesses that i really really
was mad at myself for having
the thing i'm really angry about at
myself
over the last couple of years isn't the
drug use
isn't what happened with rogan no no i
don't give a [__] about none of that
[__]
i love lee i love the pot none of that
[__] bothers me
let me tell you what bothers me about
myself that i haven't done the last
couple years
especially with this pandemic i haven't
written my book
that eats away at me more than
the loss of my mother more than
me not talking to my daughter do you
know why
because i have something i want to share
with the world
and not only that when i want to do
something
i want to [__] do it but every time i
go to sit down and write that [__]
book
i write for like three weeks and then i
start reading it
and i [__] erase it all because i
don't like it
i don't like what comes out and i'll do
this every [__] day i mean i stick to
it
see with writing it's not
listen you can buy 50 [__] thousand
books on writing
people ask me all the time hey can you
recommend comedy books to me
and i i recommend the gene parade books
or i recommend stand up comedy or i
recommend the war of art you know
writing books are great but let me tell
you something they all suck
because they're not going to tell you
what you need to know you know what you
need to know is
that you need to persevere you need to
get in every day
put two or three hours aside and write
i can't do i i got it down to a science
it's just keeping the [__] material
but now
i'm keeping it because what i was doing
before was i wasn't i
really wasn't outlining the way i should
be outlining
tj the guy that wrote the [__] book
the cuban book he told me that the
outline was
everything and i didn't [__] want out
you know i outlined it like puerto rican
style like [__] halfway
and that's why i'm getting the results
i'm getting now i'm outlining it
to the t and i'm shorting them i took a
lot of stuff out
you know you guys heard all these
stories i wanted just to give you the
story
from point a to point b of the comedy
the growth the obstacles and where i
ended up at that was
that's what the [__] story was that's
it that's what this whole thing was
i was trying to [__] give you [__]
bookmaking numbers and
stories about harlem it would have been
a book this [__] big
you would have never wrote it if they
turned it into a movie would have been
four days
a four-day [__] 24-hour marathon i
i it's and then after [__] you guys
heard already so i wanted to take
the most important part of this story
which is
july 16th the present time
sprinkling a little something in there
from the [__] past like what made me
to lead me to stand up
and that's the [__] book i wanted to
do an audio book because i know you
people
would want to hear my voice reading my
own [__] words
but i got to tell you something man i
could do that i could buy that dragonfly
is that what it's called dragonfly
and just rep read it into a thing i
could do that
i don't want to do that i want to write
i love that is my other secret dream is
to become an author
i would love to go on my twitter handle
and for it to say
author i could take off jerk off
you know what i'm saying i could take
that off my list now
jerk off uh life coach
author i can put comedian actor
writer author you know how nice that
would be
you know how much that would make me
feel especially since i'm a [__] high
school dropout
do you know what it would do for my
self-esteem so i said [__] it
this is what i'm gonna do i'm getting
surgery on the [__] eighth
i got nothing but down time i don't see
myself roller skating out there with the
[__] snow
with one [__] leg like tom segura
that ain't gonna [__] happen here
and my heart goes out to him i finally
watch that [__] tape
jesus [__] christ
and if you watch that tape you watched
how innocent
that was there was nobody around them
there was nothing really going on it
wasn't like
tom segura's a drinker or a drug addict
or nothing
that is just what i was talking about
last week when i told you when this bad
luck started
when kobe died the world is on its
access
things are happening that you cannot
understand why they're happening
don't question them every week somebody
tells you something you go what
what just happened my friends my friend
went outside to smoke a cigarette
and he came in and his wife was dead
when does that happen when does that
happen when does that happen
that a 42 year old man how old is tom 42
44. i mean great guy
you know whatever okay he's not
jacqueline
he's not in the best shape of his life
but neither am i
you know neither am i and i play with my
daughter and whatever
yeah i got to have knee surgery because
of the arthritis from both [__] knees
from lifting [__] squats when i was a
kid thinking i was [__] johnny
hercules
and running with [__] converse
sneakers you're gonna do a lot of damage
not to mention
being 300 [__] pounds for 20 years of
your [__] life
it's going to do a lot of [__] damage
but jesus christ
you know i told you last week i was at
the gym on saturday
not this saturday the saturday before
the one after christmas
and somebody had left 135 on the squat
on the bench so it's uh
the ball which is 45 pounds and 245
pound plates
45 and 45 is 90 and 45 pounds
is 135 right yeah 135 i had to double
check myself
i smoked weed this morning sometimes i
don't know so good
so
i swear to god i got under the bench
now between us and his family come on
guys i bench press 135
a thousand [__] times in my day okay
i got under the bench i looked at it i
adjusted my little chubby hips
i picked it up it felt like nothing
and for a slight second there i thought
about tom segura
i swear to my daughter and i go you know
what
we're gonna leave this where it belongs
why take a chance right now is not the
time
in fact i took my bicycle and i hid it
behind a punching bag
that [__] ain't going out for a
while because remember i fell off the
bike early this year that
i ate the [__] norco for my teeth i
fell off the bike
that was my thompson goal moment trust
me that day
my wrist still hurts it took a month for
my chest to stop hurting my chest
crashed into each other once you put
that weight on you
when i saw that and then there's the
video that i saw i didn't see any of the
other videos
uh i saw a video that a doctor posted
not really yeah there's a video of tom
segura that the doctor posted
and breaks down the whole fall oh wow
you actually hear the kneecap pop
and the slam when it hits the floor
which is horrible my heart goes after
that poor bastard
that poor bastard and he looked good i
called into the podcast
that night the two bears one came they
called me to ask me a question about
something
but it was good just to see him i missed
both those [__] guys
but so do me a favor
before you go skiing this year or any of
your other [__] uh
wild ideas think about tom segura
all right that's all i'm trying to say
to you bad luck
is going [__] around man you know i'm
even scared of doing this [__]
surgery
i don't even think the surgery will
happen i really don't i really i think
i'm gonna go for a copic test
tomorrow i gotta go yeah
tomorrow i gotta go for my colbert test
and
tuesday yeah tomorrow's tuesday i gotta
go for my kobe test and [__] uh
i think i'm gonna come back positive
[__] better than that [__] i just
you know you never [__] i mean listen
i stay at home i mind my business
i wear a mask 90 of the [__] time i
mean i don't i don't go anywhere where
there's a lot of people
i wear a mask at the gym i do everything
i have to do by the numbers but listen
my friend's mom
got it in her house and she don't leave
the house she's 85 years old
it's not like she was that [__]
generous jumping up and down
hoboken two weeks ago she didn't leave
the house and she got it
so i i don't know what to tell you
[__] people i don't know nothing i
follow the science i uh i gotta i gotta
d in science you know what i'm saying
how are you going to follow you don't
know follow the [__] science nobody
knows the [__] science so
you know i don't [__] know but i'm
scared but like the last time i took a
test was maybe two weeks ago
i went up to the to the [__] rec
center
and they had the mailing test and you
got a result but i'm hearing
such horrible [__] stories like my
buddy bought the test kit for 119
that you sent it to your house and
he bought it for the family so i guess
him
his wife and the two kids took the test
they lost the wife and his daughter's
test
and both dead tests came back negative
and then they finally found the wife's
test a week later
and they said she was positive and she's
fine
you know i just saw her like over
thursday and wednesday
so this is what i'm saying to you who
the [__] knows what's going on with
those [__] desks
you know somebody was telling me they
went in one day and got a a false
positive
and then went three days in a row and
got and got negatives
i don't know i don't know nothing about
science
i don't know what's going on with this i
just i just want this to go away
you know they're having problems some
puerto rican's arm fell off with the
vaccine
somebody was bubbling i just
can't it just end can't we just find the
pill
what what the [__] is this [__] i mean
now that and the vaccine's only for
three months
really yeah that's what i heard that the
vaccine only covers for three [__]
months
so if you get [__] uh if you get
[__]
if you get the cobit the antibodies last
for nine months
so you might as well get the [__]
covet because the antibodies
for the shot only lasts three months so
i got to put
two ice cubes in my arm twice a [__]
a month four times in a [__] year
that that's just absurd i hope that's
not true
i don't know if it's true or not but i
don't give a [__] about that [__]
enough with the [__] covert but no i
was writing myself off
i swear to god two three months ago but
especially with the podcast and stuff
i'm like this is over i'm writing myself
the [__] off
this is not working this is not and i'm
like what am i [__] crazy what am i
gonna do
what do i do i'm a podcaster i'm a comic
i'm a [__] writer so i gotta get it
together
so i wrote my goals down i sat the [__]
down and i'm like this is what needs to
be [__] done this year
i need to outline this [__] book i
need to outline in three week chapters
in three chapters at a time write the
chapters
and send them to him on friday that's
the [__] plan right now
that's the plan so i'm i'm i got like
one more chapter to outline
write three chapters every chapter send
it to him on friday
start the chapter on sunday and all this
[__] down time i have
[__] go to a diner with a mask on
just put a mask on
and get a coffee and [__] get like a
little straw
somebody's gonna invent the [__] mask
with a little straw
trust me somebody's gonna invent it sail
tight and you can sit there and drink
your coffee
and that's what i'm gonna do because i'm
not gonna [__] die without writing
this book
because here's the problem guys i don't
want just want to write one book
i want to write a couple [__] books
like i got a couple books in this
[__] coconut
i got a book about my life i got a book
i want to write
about comedy i got a story i want to
write about a a
uh a successful
guy and a politician that grow up
together and one becomes
whatever i got ideas i got ideas you
know what i'm saying
uh i like to be a writer like right now
i'm
thinking of pitching the show again once
this blows over
you know there's going to be some
interest with the soprano movie so we
might as well get some
[__] the soprano movie uh
many saints in newark i think it's not
going to come on much guys i'm not here
to disappoint you
i'm just letting you know what i'm
hearing through the grapevines and what
i'm reading
i haven't gotten an official anything
from them
but just from what i'm reading online
it's going to get pushed back so
whatever so
we're all going to have to wait to
whatever listen man
i don't know about you guys you ever
watch a movie in your [__] house
it's interesting but not really
see a lot of people go i'd rather be in
my house the coziness of my house
i like to be in my house too but there's
a problem in my house
and it's called the refrigerator and
it's called the phone
and it's called a computer and it's
called the cat
and it's called [__] a thousand
[__] things
you know a light in the ceiling a noise
something a text
that's what i don't like about watching
movies at home that i can't
submerse myself there's only two places
i could submerge myself in a movie
in a movie theater or on a [__] plane
you go on a [__] plane they ain't
no no look at either you look at the
thing and look at clouds and look for
ufos
because everybody's seen ufos these days
so everybody's looking for [__] ufos
or [__] look straight ahead i enjoy
the movie theater experience
if i got to watch a new movie in my
house
i'm not going to enjoy it that much you
know i watch them on paper you don't get
me wrong
you know i like the green book i liked
all that stuff but
i'd much rather i'm old school
i grew up in a [__] movie theater i
grew up on saturdays that's what you did
you either went to buy a record or you
went to the [__] movies or both
we used to do both catch a movie and
then walk down bergen line
boom buy a [__] album and bam there
you were your [__] house an hour
later
so you know to me i i'd rather be at a
movie theater
so i don't know what to tell you [__]
people if you're mad
i don't know don't get mad at me get mad
at [__] coronavirus
i'm not the one that closed down the
adidas go take up your beef with johnny
amc
you know and but i did hear this i
did hear you could rent the [__]
movie theater for
[__] dirt cheap sounds fun too
it seems like fun i think i'm doing it
for mercy's birthday because
i might not be able to even go to
[__] birthday but i know she's making
calls
today about either one of the places
around here like a
a place where you like a zone place or
something like that
it's in freehold i think somewhere
and then uh there's a movie theater
somewhere we just found out that you can
rent it for 10 kids
you bring your own food like it's
[__] crazy [__] it's
crazy [__] and they have a selection of
movies
that you can watch so it's not
everything like you're not going to be
able to you know like go oh i want to
no they have a selection of movies that
you could watch i don't know
how in depth the selection is or
whatever it's all up to you i have no
[__] idea
but what i was talking about was that
yeah after i watch that rocky thing
that's what i want to do i rather really
take this into it like this is what this
you know like a caterpillar becomes a
butterfly or the other way
does a butterfly become a caterpillar
one of those like i'm [__] cocooning
man
i'm changing and i listen in march
i said this on the church that people
were going to change
i didn't even i think but in march i
also
thought we would be going back in june
so i was wrong right there
or it's [__] january 2021
and we're still in it and in about a
[__] month
eight weeks we're gonna be in it for a
[__] year so
and i haven't done [__] in a year except
move
do a podcast lose a little weight
and work out i haven't really yeah we've
done the joey diaz project and patreon
all that [__]
and i did the reshoots for the sopranos
and what
not reshoots added scenes but i haven't
really done much
so i think that uh this is the [__]
time to do it right now
and guess what i'm excited about it
i'm listen this is what i always dreamed
about man
i read about hemingway that [__]
was a bad [__]
you know and towards the end he would go
to [__] cuba and just drink and write
i'm not all about the drinking and stuff
but i'm about
all those writers had the same thing in
comic browkowski
and all those [__] dudes that got
drunk
they love people watching
people watching they're looking for
characters
i love characters i don't like whether i
think i don't like california
fake characters they're all fake
characters
they all want to be belushi you know i
was watching that documentary by belushi
there's a documentary on showtime that's
not bad
i'm a big fan of belushi you know to a
point there's a
i'm a big fan of belushi's he was
buckwild
no [__] safety net just [__] an
animal
a lot of people too young to remember
john belushi from cyanide live
just a [__] lunatic animal house was
on two nights ago
and i watched 15 minutes of it to toga
scene i was
[__] dying i was [__] dying it was
so funny
the guy was pure i mean listen
farley wanted to be belushi i think
candy just wanted to be johnny candy
candy was a bad [__]
but there's been 20 [__] that
have wanted to be belushi
uh john uh what's his name
chris farley came close i mean he out
partied the [__] out of volusia
i think they both died when they were
33. pollution diamond he was [__] 33
years old
at the [__] whatever hotel up the
corner from the comedy store there
was i a belushi fan yes i love animal
house
[__] yeah but i love blues brothers oh
my [__] god i love blues brothers
you know but i don't know how we started
talking about belushi
anyway everybody wants them everybody
wants to be belushi
every [__] year i shot a pilot i shot
five pilots for fox
and one year i shot a pilot
that the guy was belushi
he wanted to be belushi so [__] bad
but he did such a fake impersonation of
it
like he was one of those guys that was
trying to act great like i'm crazy
okay how crazy are you i'll walk in here
naked
that's not crazy enough
what do you mean walking naked anybody
could do that
taking a [__] on the floor picking it up
and eating it that's crazy do that you
should see his little face
he almost died he was from like ohio
somewhere
he almost [__] died when i told him
that
pilot never got picked up he went back
to ohio
all those belushi wannabes they don't
[__] last
long in [__] l.a but who the [__]
cares about belushi i was just
like you know that i was watching the
documentary it's not bad it's very
entertaining it's like the comedy stores
in that same genre in fact it had
the week after the [__] comedy store
so back to the rocky balboa thing
i'm 58 and i'm not giving up yet that's
it that's all i wanted to tell you is
today
that for a long the last month the last
six weeks
i've had doubts i've had doubts from the
podcast
you know i know this wasn't what you
guys wanted
or you guys expected you know i love my
man mike
so i just wanted to come in here and
talk [__] because the plan is this
once this [__] gets kicking up i'm going
to get an office
i want to get an office with a screen
and i want to do all the [__]
i want to do in that bar area but that
bar is also a part of my living house
so if i was to do that over that i would
take away from my [__] family
like i was gone one day this week and
girls were over here and they were in
that room
you know they were in that room i can't
keep drugs in that room i can't [__]
have weed in that room
or bungs sticking out that's the way to
the backyard
so even though i had plans and i had all
these big [__] deals
it was still my house and the girls are
gonna have access to it
and now she's got toys down here and
[__] so now i can't really [__] use
it
i might have a guest uh on wednesday and
we might use it just for the guest just
to [__] get out of the way
but besides that i can't turn that into
a podcast studio like i wanted to
i really wanted to [__] make that a
great studio but
it's part of the [__] house they
could hear everything upstairs
i'm down there smoking weed that thing
goes right through the [__] thing
the other night i smoked down here in
this room and i had to [__]
leave the windows open because you could
smell in the [__] kitchen my wife
almost had a heart attack
so let me do what i got to do you know i
come to use every [__] week
i'm not going no way you know you still
got me i keep you posted
this is completely free you know how we
do it
i'm just telling you my struggles that's
the plan and then me and mike could get
an office
nice and nice put up the brick wall
again
some noises some [__] sacrifice
somebody
light some people on fire get some
edibles going
you know you don't you understand i'm
trying to say to you this
[__] steps guys this wasn't gonna
take a [__] month and a half
but i wasn't just gonna stop doing the
podcast august 15th
and show up february first and go hey
how are you
hello because you were to go [__] you
[__]
you left us flat you left this without
dick in our hands
this at least you get 50 of me and ain't
the best [__] joey dears you're gonna
get
but at least you get [__] something
at least you know you're getting the
[__] right answer from me the truth
and i'm telling you what's going on with
my world and i'm giving you a little
[__] story to boot
right or wrong you got a little story
out of this nobody loses no [__] face
is it snowing out there yet no it looks
like it's gonna [__] snow today
who gives a [__] anymore guys we're in
jersey it's a whole new [__] year
listen man the pandemic was a bad thing
what are you gonna [__] do
but we're still gonna cry about it it's
a new year we already gone through it
you already went to the bulk of it
let's [__] rock out the rest of it do
this is what i'm gonna do
why you think i just said [__] it i
could sit here every day and keep
feeling sorry for myself
is that what you want to do my gym is
closed i can't do this
i can't do that that's something you got
to be able to be able to do
there's something that you should be
able to do
deliver groceries there's no reason
why you should be [__] alone or
feeling the way you're feeling
because i was starting to feel like that
and i got a family and a wife and a kid
and a giant and i was starting to feel
like [__] i was being worthless
and i said enough of that [__] already i
would feel like i had one foot in the
grave want a banana peel no i don't
no i don't i'm more alive than i've ever
[__] been in my life
i'm better than i've ever been in my
life i can't wait to get on [__]
stage tomorrow night and wednesday night
i wrote a couple of things nothing
shabelish
but it's still [__] joey diaz coming
at you you know what i'm saying
and all you people expect to see
chappelle and thought and
smoking a cigarette but you know
chappelle's chappelle uncle joey's uncle
[__] joey so
you gotta you gotta recognize whatever
the [__] you want to do you know what
i'm saying
and that's it and that's that i'm just
here on a [__] monday morning
to greet you and let you know i love you
man
i didn't forget about you [__]
and i didn't give up either
but it's true for the last month and a
half i've just been feeling down
not down not not depressed
but just like the wind has been taken
out of my sails a little bit
that's it sometimes in life you feel
like the wind has been taken out of your
sails
that's how i feel but then i was
realizing like what the [__] am i what
am i gonna do
just retire i think this year
once the [__] thing is over i'm going
to shoot more movies than i've ever shot
before i said you ever have that feeling
i have that feeling like that's why i
was going to [__] call it quits with
sag because they changed everything
around
all the insurance policies and the
[__] guidelines and stuff
and i'm like i'm not quitting i'm not
i'm not quitting
for years i've been sitting here telling
you not to [__] quit
and here i am thinking about quitting
how would i look to you guys what would
that make me [__] be
a [__] quitter so sorry about that
that's one of those left side burps it
comes out of the other side you ever get
those burps
it's a burp but not really it comes out
of here like a yo
it comes out of here like a little burp
on the side sorry about that
they come from the stomach whatever the
[__] but no what would i look like if i
quit
so i'm gonna turn it around instead of
quitting i'm gonna work a little harder
towards it
the problem with writing for me is
you're not going to [__] believe this
when i tell you
when i sit down to write if i write
five days let's say my schedule would be
sunday through friday and i email it to
him friday afternoon
i would have to sit down in an hour and
chunks and then get up and do something
for an hour
and then come back and go to the next
part of the outline and write off from
that that's how i'm going to do it
i have been trying this through trial
and error
it's [__] embarrassing guys it's
embarrassing how far i've been
i had a guy who was an editor for a
while helping me
i had a girl helping me for a while i
had another girl helping me for a while
and i've had help and you want me to
tell you what this is starting to feel
like to me
comedy remember i told you it took me a
long time to get into stand-up comedy
because i was scared of what might have
happened
history repeats itself all the time guys
if you don't get to know you
you're never going to get to grow you
got to get to know
you that's why i tell people i'm like a
broken [__] record with the notebook
in the journal
why do you think i'm like a broken
record with the notebook in the journal
because you could always go back and
look
and see what you were thinking
and it hit me it hit me when i was
outlining
the [__] book because
the first part of the book is me
stalling
why was i stalling
because i was scared of what might
happen
there's two things that could happen if
i write a book are you ready
it could either fail miserably
or it could open up a thousand [__]
doors
both of those options work for me
right like both of those options work
for me
as long as i write the book
are you with me i don't mind
failing i don't mind that
i feel every day it's something i i
don't mind
i feel social studies and after that i
got used to it you know what i'm saying
once you feel social studies you're like
[__] it i'm used to this [__]
stupidity
i'm not scared of failure it's not doing
that i'm scared of that's when i start
getting worried
when i won't go in the garage and throw
kettlebells why don't i want to do
kettlebells today
there's a rea let me go out there and do
a couple kettlebells you do three or
four swings now next thing you know
you're up to ten swings
you did ten times ten swings and you hit
the bag a little bit you gotta work out
this riding [__] is just like my
stand-up family
same thing i'm scared of what might
happen
so i wrote out what might happen
what happens if joey diaz writes this
book
and there was two answers it could
either be well received
maybe they could maybe i could make a
movie of my life oh
[__] yeah maybe they could turn it into
a tv show
i'm too old for that drama you imagine
me on a tv show and then
abc telling me we can't do numbers you
have to
make believe you're betting pony here go
away
you know your mom can't do santeria she
has to be a christian
go [__] yourself i don't want to do this
for a tv show
i don't want to do this for a movie i
just want to do this to prove it to
myself that i could do it
stan hope did it jim florentine did it
all my friends did it i'm the only
[__] bert christian [__] wrote a
book drunk
and i can't [__] write a book you
know how bad i [__] feel
bert kreischer wrote the book with pedo
in one hand and a feather in the other
and i can't write a [__] book and
you know what i'm saying do you know how
bad i [__] feel right now
but at least i'm not ashamed you know
this is what i tell you people
i'm not ashamed to tell people the truth
because this is how you get help it's by
telling people the truth that
you don't know how to do something i
have always
asked for help if i don't know what i'm
doing man
[__] you all these mother oh i went on
youtube
and i looked and told me to do this why
did i know the house was gonna blow up
you dumb [__] i tried to tell you
you call the [__] electrician there's
some stuff you could do on your own yeah
bake a cake [__] like that other [__]
you got to call a professional or ask
questions would you invest like a
million dollars if you didn't know
anything
no you got to ask questions so i asked
questions i went online
you know when when i finish the podcast
i'm calling my agent
and i'm letting them know my plans i
didn't want to tell them
because i've already told this guy a
thousand stories i'm embarrassed
he called me before the holidays to skip
my address to send me a christmas card
and i was too embarrassed to even
send him the [__] address because
he's been nothing but great to me
he even outlined the book for me the
whole book for me
the one he wanted me to write he
outlined it for me
and i and i'm so stupid i still can't
[__] do it
so it was just too much
so i can't let him him down i cannot let
him down
so my primary goal this year
and i'm saying it right here and you
guys are going to hold me to it
december 31st you guys are all going to
send me tweets
and call me a [__] loser your mother
sucked dick
i want you to say everything you can to
insult me if i don't come up with a book
my goal is
to have this book written by the [__]
summer
and to do that i got to sit there five
days a week
maybe yeah
i'm gonna do three three-hour sittings
so it's three hours and 45 [__]
minutes a day
on this book and you know what i got the
time trust me
i think around eight hours a [__] day
with nothing to do
i work i do different [__] i do [__]
around the house i help with my daughter
i help with my wife you know i got
different responsibilities
but you know what there's still a little
time there i can do
i can't ride at night because then i get
too caught up and i get nightmares and i
have dreams about my life and [__] like
that
so i gotta get up early that means i'm
gonna start shutting the tv off earlier
you know i don't even watch that much tv
i i eat dinner
i answer the patreon messages i take a
shower
and then i go out there with the girls
about 8 30.
mercy goes to bed at 9 30 nine o'clock
i go in there by 9 30 and check on him
my wife goes in around
10. once she goes in i put my little
teacup my little [__] kika malty in
i'd throw a [__] edible in there
because i only eat the edibles to get
high throw him in that asleep
i throw the kikimo edible in there i
stare it up
i call lee i let the tea [__] you can
ask lee i do this every [__] day i
got the same schedule every day
i call lee i let the tea simmer down
then i drink my tea
i give me a half hour and i go to bed
that's the same [__] i [__] do
every [__] night so i think from now
on i'm gonna change that around
i'm gonna come down after dinner do the
patreon messages
and write an hour that's gonna be the
last hour of the day
then take a shower and then hang out
with the girls
i'll write an hour and a half in the
morning
do my other responsibilities and then
come back mid-afternoon and write
another hour and a half when i'm fresh
that's the only way i'm going to do this
and it's taken me eight years to figure
this out guys
eight [__] years so
i'm going for it with your blessing
this is what i do this is what i need to
do like when i joined jiu jitsu i didn't
tell him one of my friends
i didn't tell eddie or joe or ari i
didn't tell anybody
just in case i quit i wouldn't have to
hear from them
by the way i did stop at a jiu jitsu
school on saturday
it's a smaller school it's more of a
mom-and-pop
type school and i'm gonna have the knee
surgery
and once i have the knee surgery and i'm
ready to go
maybe may june i'm gonna start doing i'm
gonna lift
i've already got my uh physical therapy
[__]
set up with a friend of mine dave baton
i grew up with
he's gonna do all the physical therapy
he's big on this
and uh i'm just looking for the best man
right now i'm just looking
for a better 2021 and what i got to do
to
make the year work and my primary goal
this year is not to write a comedy
special
none of that [__] is to write a [__]
book and i got the plan
and thanks to you guys now i gotta
[__] walk the walk see you can talk
the dog
but now you gotta walk the walk
and with that that's it it's monday
morning
it's the beginning of a great [__]
week it's the beginning of a great year
you know when everybody said it was
gonna be a great year
i i didn't i didn't want you guys to
think that you're gonna wake up monday
and [__] you know people there's
gonna be a parade on the [__] street
i mean
it was a shame not to see a parade on
new year's day i didn't know the rose
bowl
wasn't going to be in california this
year i didn't know a lot of things
that just broke my heart but it is what
it is
hopefully the next new year's we'll be
able to go back to normal
and uh spend it with our families and
friends and smoke pot and
do heroin and eat [__] and eat ass and
spitting somebody's [__] all these
things
you could do again next year but this
year we just had to be cool and that's
it
anyway i want to thank you guys for
having my back
for supporting the patreon i'm happy you
guys got the shirts the shirts are cool
and [__] i'm happy you got them uh
everything's working out and i'll see
you at uncle benny's tuesday
and wednesday night and now i'll see you
back here wednesday morning
tip top magoo stay black [__]
uncle joey loves you support
thank you again for listening today for
a fun-filled podcast i hope you got
something out of it
i know i did i feel like [__] now anyway
uh the the joint is brought to you by
cbdlion.com
one of my favorites why because i'm old
and i'm sore
and i got pains and when you got pains
and ailments
and you're trying to work out and trying
to be healthy it's tough out there for a
pimp
but that's where the cbd line comes in
whether it's the kinesiology tape
whether it's the bath balls the gummies
which are fantastic
i'll pop three of those and that's
better than the [__] oxycontin you
understand me
you got the vapor you got the cbd line
roll on
if see if you want to if you want cbd
cbd lion has the answer no more going to
the [__] liquor store
or going to a sneaker store or some
[__] yeah
are you [__] [__] cbdline.com go
to the website
read up on cbd cbn
term terrapins whatever the [__] they
call them
see even i'm learning [__] go to
cbdlion.com
they got gummies that'll knock you the
[__] tropical will
knock your [__] dick off you
understand me any way you put it
or cbdline.com and you get a discount 20
off temp but whatever the [__] they're
feeling that day they'll take care of
you their family
cbdlion.com joey
the joint is also brought to you by my
favorite
movement watches holy [__]
listen i've been working with them for
about three years i have a watch that i
wear
but they sent me this beautiful element
international watch
and these dust sunglasses and black
i look like a [__] johnny j mooch
but i love them to death i put them on
when i'm watching them when i'm
looking at the computer i put them on
when i'm driving
tremendous listen 2021 is gonna be the
year of doing it on your own
all right movement watches it's two
college dropouts
that took on the watch industry and look
where they are today all right
they focused and look what they did what
they wanted to do
was give you high looking [__] priced
watches
at affordable prices that's what they
wanted to do
these watches are unfucking believable
they look great
people look at you and go what the [__]
you driving the testerosa
look how sharp they are you understand
me that's a watch i have
an international that's what i'm talking
about movement watches look like they
cost a whole paycheck
but they cost what you you used to spend
the night out
get a beautiful watch ship right to you
for free
i if you don't love it you send it back
there's no worries
if you're like me you spend a lot of
time in front of a computer
get some ever scroll blue light glasses
that's what i'm telling you right here
they're tremendous they help with the
eye strain bad
sleep and headaches everybody's been
saying joey you're looking a lot better
than lately
yeah because i'm taking care of myself
and i wear these things when i look at
the computer
so you don't have bags under your
[__] eyes you're like you're 90 years
old even though i do have bags under my
eyes
but my point here movement watches
they sell the best watches shades
jewelry and at a fair price
in 160 countries around the world
they're making us look good so do me a
favor
if you want to elevate your [__] look
with with style
i mean you want to look good you want
the [__] to look at you at the bar
and go that
[__] he didn't have kovitz look
at him
go to movement right now right now get
off with free shipping and free returns
we don't like to watch send it back and
get a different one they're okay with
that
go by mvmt.com joey again
go to mvmt.com
joey don't be a [__] moot you want to
look cool this year
this is the way to start with the nice
little movement watch right there
i want to thank movement and i want to
thank cbd lion
for having our back on this monday the
first monday
of the [__] year i hope you guys have
a great week
we'll be back wednesday tip top
[__] magoo
ready to go
i love you [__] have a great week
thank you
you